what do you think is the most amazing or
maybe the coolest measurement device
you've ever worked with or humans have
ever built maybe for now let's exclude
the background Imaging of cosmic extra
Galactic polarization instruments yeah
I'm slightly biased towards that
particular instrument but I'll talk
about that in a little bit Yeah but
certainly the telescope to me is is a
lever that has literally moved the Earth
uh throughout history so the OG
telescope the OG telescope yeah the one
invented not by Galileo as most people
think but by this guy Hans lipochet in
uh in the Netherlands and you know it
was kind of interesting because in the
1600s 14 1500 1600s it was the beginning
of movable type and so people for the
first time in history uh had a standard
by which they could appraise their
eyesight so looking at a printed word
now we just take it for granted 12 point
font whatever and that's what the eye
charts are based on they're just fixed
height but back then there were no
there's no way to adjust your eyesight
if you didn't have uh you know perfect
vision and there was no way to even tell
if you had perfect vision or not until
the Gutenberg Bible and movable type and
at that time people realized hey wait I
can't read this you know my priest or my
friend over here he can read it she can
read it I can't read it what's going on
and that's when you know these people in
in Venice and then the Netherlands saw
that they could take this kind of you
know glass material and hold it up and
maybe put another piece of glass
material and it would make it clearer
and what was so interesting is that
nobody thought to take that exact same
device you know two lenses and go like
let me go like this and look at that
bright thing in the sky over there uh
until Galileo so Galileo didn't invent
it but he did something kind of amazing
he improved on it by a factor of 10. so
he 10xed it which is almost as good as
going from zero to one is going from you
know one to ten and when he did that he
really
transformed both how we look at the
universe and think about it but also who
we are as a as a species because we're
using tools not to get food faster or to
you know preserve you know uh our our
Legacy for the for future Generations
but actually to increase the benefit of
to the human mind somebody mentioned
this idea that uh if humans weren't able
to see the star maybe there was some
some kind of um
make above the atmosphere which for the
early humans made it impossible to see
the stars that we would never develop
human civilization or at least raising
the question of how important is it to
look up to the sky and wonder what's out
there as opposed to
um maybe this is an over romanticized
notion but like looking at the ground it
feels like a little bit too much focused
on Survival not being eaten by a bear
slash lion if you look up to the Stars
you start to wonder what is my place in
the universe you think I think that's uh
modern humans it's a little romantic um
because they also took the trade
they took the same two lenses and they
looked inward right they looked at
bacteria they looked at you know my
hairs and in other words they made the
microscope and we're still doing that
and so you know to have a telescope is
it serves a dual purpose it's it's not
only a way of looking out it's looking
in but it's also looking back in time in
other words you can see a microscope you
don't think oh I'm seeing this thing as
it was you know one nanosecond ago light
travels one foot per nanosecond oh I'm
seeing internet no you don't think about
it like that but when you see something
that's half happening you know on
Jupiter the moon Andromeda galaxy you're
seeing things you know back when Lucy
was walking around the Serengeti Plains
and for that I think that took then the
knowledge of you know relativity and
time travel and and so forth it took
that before we could really say oh we we
really unlocked some cheat codes in the
human brain so I I think that might be a
little too much but but nevertheless I
mean what's better than having a time
machine you know it's like we can look
back in time we see things as they were
not as they are and that allows us to do
many things including speculate about
that but one of the coolest things I
don't know if you're familiar with
someone radio astronomer I don't
actually look through telescopes very
often except uh you know on rare
occasions when I when I take one out uh
to show the kids but
um but a radio telescope as even more
sort of visceral I mean it's much less
cool because you look at it you're like
all right it looks cool it's kind of
weird shape thing looks like it belongs
in sci-fi it's going to blast uh you
know uh the Death Star or whatever but
when you um when you realize that when
you point a radio telescope at a
distance on object if that object fills
up what's called The Beam which is
basically the field of view of a radio
telescope is called this beam if you
fill up the beam and you put a resistor
just a simple absorbing piece of
material at the focus of the radio
telescope that resistor will come to the
exact same temperature as the object
it's looking at which is pretty amazing
it means you're actually remotely
measuring you're taking the temperature
of Jupiter or whatever in in effect and
so it's it's allowing you to basically
teleport and there's no other science
that you can really do that right if
you're an archaeologist you can let me
get into my you know my time machine and
go back and say what was Lucy really
like you know it's not possible so this
the same thing happens this is where
I've learned about this from March of
the Penguins when the Penguins huddle
together they uh you know the body
temperature arrives to the same place so
you're you're doing this remotely this
is the march of the Penguins but remote
when you do it from Antarctica too so
there are some penguins around when we
do it